in today's warning rounds we are looking
at why mental health care is not always
covered by health insurance we've
partnered with kaiser Health News and
NPR on their bill of the month series
which uncovers shocking medical bills
and shocking is the word the latest
explains how an Illinois woman owes tens
of thousands of dollars after a mental
health crisis in a very unexpected
hospital stay it's just you know one
thing after the other after the other
Arlene Phelan was mourning the deaths of
her father and husband when she received
a third blow the cherry on top of the
cake was when I lost my mom that's when
I just I'm like God I just can't how can
I do this after an emotional mother's
day she spent a night drinking and
texting a worried friend called 9-1-1
Phelan was rushed to a hospital in the
Chicago suburbs where she spent four
nights in the psychiatric unit I kept
asking questions you know what is this
gonna cost me I'm underinsured I am
insured but I'm underinsured Phelan had
purchased a low price insurance plan
that's not part of the Affordable Care
Act and it does not cover mental health
I'd say six to eight weeks to receive my
initial bills and I keep getting bills I
mean they're still coming feelin's
initial hospital bill covering
behavioral care lab work and room
charges totaled nearly 30 thousand
dollars the ambulance was an additional
$1,400 northwestern Medicine central
DuPage hospital later reduced its charge
by almost nine thousand dollars leaving
her owing twenty one thousand six
hundred and thirty-four dollars the
hospital tells CBS News quote we have
tried numerous times to connect with his
patient to provide guidance and
assistance our follow-up efforts remain
active and we hope to hear from the
patient soon Phelan sister Kathy is
helping her navigate her bills but
Phelan says she's worried about
collection notices every time she picks
up her mail it adds some stress and some
fright you know actually what's what's
next never good when you don't want to
pick up the mail the editor and she
of kaiser Health News is dr. Elizabeth
Rosenthal she joins us now at the table
good good to see you doctor
thanks for so so she said she had
insurance did it turned out she just
didn't have the right kind of insurance
yes for financial reasons she bought a
cheaper kind of health plan called an
association health plan which you can
opt out of certain kinds of coverage so
psychiatric care mental health care
prescription drug coverage and under the
Affordable Care Act those plans were
considered junk insurance or skinny
plans and what we see with this story is
if you opt for that plan you're leaving
yourself vulnerable because you can't
really predict what kinds of health care
you're gonna need aside from the low
cost there were other reasons people
choose these plans mostly because they
don't understand what kinds of gaps they
they leave them vulnerable to but it's
mostly a cost thing you know with
premiums and deductibles going up a lot
of people look at the ACA plans and say
oh I just can't afford it this is better
than nothing and better than nothing but
if you have certain kinds of health
conditions that you didn't predict
you're totally vulnerable so if you find
yourself in a situation where you have a
skinny plan the plan didn't cover it
everything and you've got thousands of
bills what do you do oh my gosh you're
in a bed you're in bad position because
basically you're vulnerable it's kind of
a double whammy you don't have the
insurer to pay for the service but also
you don't have the the insurers
negotiated rates which in this case you
know the the the rack rate was thirty
thousand dollars most insurers would
have paid maybe nine thousand so you
know they gave her a 30% discount great
because she was uninsured but that's
still 20 something thousand dollars an
unaffordable but how do you know you
have a bad plan I think she's singing
look I have insurance I'm covered how do
you know you how do you even know you've
got something you know as every time I
come here I say buyer beware right you
really really have to know the limits of
your plan and you know PS when you're in
a mental health crisis you need care
she's better now
it really wasn't an option to stay at
home so this is one of those situations
where we leave patients in really
untenable and unaffordable positions
right dr. Elizabeth Rosenthal thank you
for joining us today
so much for having for a full link to
the kaiser Health News story go to our
website CBS this morning dot-com